for god's sake this man cannot remain in  power mr president  [Music]  mr president were you calling for regime  change  no  wow all right but just hours ago biden  claiming none of what you just heard him  say is actually true  i'm not walking anything back  the fact of the matter is i was  expressing the more outrage i felt  toward the way putin is  dealing and the actions of this man  personal feelings sir  the idea that he is going to do  something outrageous because i called  him for what he was and what he's doing  i think is just not rational nobody  believes we're going to take down i was  going to i was talking about taking down  putin  nobody believes that  okay so judge he's it's our fault